today here at celebration London it's
it's kind of the very first time I've
stood up in front of Star Wars fans and
gotten to talk at all about Episode
eight and we only did a little bit
because it's mostly about rogue one this
year and the focus is on that next year
in Orlando is really where it will come
out and really get to talk about those
it was fun gang that just stand up in
front of you know the the elite fans the
fan band fan fans and really yeah just
give even just like a little
introduction to kind of what we're up to
last year in Anaheim I went just to
watch when the force awakens was having
their their whole rollout at celebration
and I got to just walking around the
floor and got to just sit in the crowd
and so it was I'm really happy I got to
do that last year and just experience it
from the crowd and just feel kind of the
the energy out there and like the
positivity and and so stand sitting up
on stage which is terrifying Friday and
like the wrong side of the lights for me
I like being behind the lights but
lastly having been out there and known
that just singing in the audience is
people who love this so much and are so
into it and so rooting for it to be
something really special you know it it
felt good really good for me the
experience has been about my experience
with these act wonderful actors on set
and with the people at Lucasfilm just
telling us figuring out the story to
tell and just all of us kind of coming
together is this a little family to tell
a story that we care about and I'm so
happy they they cast Alden in that part
I just think he's perfect for it and I
you could feel the crowd like embracing
him when he came out it's cool to see
him step into that role it's gonna I
can't wait to see it
you